الجاسوس الذي غفل عنه العراق
، أرسله وطنه ليكمل دارسته ولتدريبه على الطيران
، ويعود ليخدم بلده الذي أطعمه وألبسه ورعاه
ويرعى عائلته،
نسي الجاسوس كل شيء
وذهب ليعمل مع المخابرات الإسرائيلية،
لماذا قد يخون الشخص وطنه،
ولماذا اختارته المخابرات الإسرائيلية دوناً عن غيره؟،
وما هو دور الCIA المخابرات الأمريكية
في الموضوع؟
(عن الجاسوس الإسرائيلي ذي الأصول العراقية
منير روفا نتحدث وللقصة بقية
بدأت القصة عندما أراد الاتحاد السوفييتي
تسليح دول الشرق الأوسط المناهضة لأمريكا وإسرائيل
خصوصا دولتا مصر والعراق
، وفي بداية عام ١٩٦١ وحتى ١٩٦٣
تخلل هذه الفترة حصول مصر والعراق
على أقوى سلاح جوي في ذلك الوقت،
وهي طائرة ميج21،
حيث اتسم هذا النوع من الطائرات بسرعة خارقة
تفوق سرعة الصوت،
ما جعل أمريكا وإسرائيل تسعيان خلفها
لمعرفة آلية صنعها،
لكنهما لم تستطيعان ذلك،،،
وبعد تسليح العراق من الاتحاد السوفييتي
سحبت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية دعمها
وأعادت مدربيها الذين يعملون في العراق،
إلا أن الرئيس العراقي  عبدالكريم قاسم
حاول إعادة المياه لمجاريها، وأعاد العلاقات مع أمريكا
إلى سابق عهدها، وإظهارا لحسن نيته
قرر إرسال دفعة من أفضل طياري العراق ليكملوا تدريبهم في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
انتهزت المخابرات الأمريكية بدعم من الموساد الإسرائيلي الفرصة
، فهم لم يستطيعوا أخذ أي طائرة ميج21 من
مصر أو معلومات عنها،
وبينما الطيارون العراقيون منير روفا، وحامد الضاحي،
وشاكر محمود يتلقون تدريباتهم أثناء تواجدهم في أمريكا،
حاول الCIA إغواء الطيارين كلا على حده،
فبدأوا بحامد الضاحي الذي رفض الخيانة رفضا قطعيا
رغم تهديدهم له ولعائلته أو محاولة إغرائه بالمال
لكن ذلك لم يجدِ نفعا مع الضاحي
وراح ضحية حادث مروري  مدبر،
لم تنتبه المخابرات العراقية للحادث آنذاك،
ثم عاد الأمريكان للطيار الثاني وهو محمود شاكر
، فقبل تحت التهديد  وبعد معرفته بما حدث لزميله الضاحي
، وأظهر رغبته في المقابل الذي سيحصل عليه،
فعل منير روفا الأمر ذاته وقبل بالخيانة،،،
(الوفاء والخيانة)
وما إن عاد منير ومحمود  إلى أرض الوطن حتى التقت بهم المخابرات الأمريكية
هناك في بغداد، وكررت عليهم عواقب
عدم تنفيذهم لمهمة اختطاف إحدى طائرات ميج21،
عندها وبكل شجاعة أعلن محمود شاكر
رفضه خيانة قسمه الذي أقسمه للوطن،
ورفض الخيانة بأي شكل كان
، وما هي إلا أيام معدودة حتى فاحت رائحة جثته في الفندق الذي يقيم فيه،
وبعد أن رأى منير روفا ما حصل لزميليه وافق على الخيانة
وبدأ بنقل المعلومات للموساد وبدأت خطة عملية اختطاف الطائرة،،،
وبينما يحاول الموساد نشر رواية أخرى ليثبتوا قوتهم وذكاءهم،
بقولهم إن منير روفا تم اختطافه بعد أن تم تخديره ونقله لإسرائيل
والتقاط صور له مع عناصر الموساد وتهديده بها،
عندها علم منير أنه إذا ظهرت هذه الصور فسيتم إعدامه حتما في العراق،
وقبل بالخيانة،،،
لكن هذه رواية ليس عليها أي دليل،،،
(عملية الاختطاف)
بدأت العملية بترحيل زوجة منير روفا وأطفاله في اليوم الذي يسبق العملية
، ليضمن منير أن الموساد لن يتركه لعاقبته،
وفي يوم ال١٥ من سبتمبر ١٩٦٦،
وخلال إجراء عدد من الطيارين لمناورات تدريبية،
كان الموساد قد ساعد بملئ الطائرة بوقود احتياطي
بديلا عن الأسلحة ما يكفي للوصول إلى إسرائيل
بدأت المناورات، وأخذ منير يقود الطائرة بسرعتها القصوى
وعندما لاحظ زملاؤه خروجه عن مساره حاولوا تنبيهه
فرد بأنه يحاول إجراء مناورات جديدة،
ولم تكد الرادارات العراقية أن تلاحظ خيانة منير وهروبه
إلا وقد خرج من حدود العراق فالطائرة سريعة سرعة خارقة،
ونجح الخائن بعملية الاختطاف...
(الهبوط في أرض العدو)..
ما إن تجاوز منير الحدود العراقية ودخل في حدود الأردن
حتى حاول الأردنيون تنبيهه أنه قد دخل حدودهم،
لكنه تجاهل ذلك وواصل مسيره ولم يستطع الأردنيون
إسقاط الطائرة لشدة سرعتها، بعد ذلك دخل منير في الأجواء الإسرائيلية
وتجاهل إنذاراتهم وبينما كانت الدفاعات الجوية بصدد إسقاطه
جاءت الأوامر بعدم إلحاق الضرر به والسماح له بالهبوط،
وبعد هبوط منير روفا في المطار الإسرائيلي
، عقد مؤتمر صحفي وتحدث عن أسباب خيانته لوطنه
وقال إنه لم يشعر بالأمان في العراق وشعر بأنه ليس وطنه،
ومُنح الجنسية الإسرائيلية، وتوجه إلى أمريكا بعد أن تلقى المال مقابل خيانته،،
على الرغم أن العراق أخذت منير الروفا وهو مسيحي الجنسية
وقد جاءها لاجئا من الحدود الإيرانية التركية،
فتم تعليمه وترقيته والسماح له بالدخول في القوات المسلحة العراقية،
وتمت رعايته وعائلته واعتُبر أحد أبناء الوطن
إلا أن الخيانة جرت في عروقه ونسي من أعاده للحياة،
فهل استحق العراق خيانة كهذه؟